Jake says I've been incredibly inspired
by you love what you do and would like
to enlighten people in a similar manner
be careful what you wish for
it is is it appropriate to aim to have
as much as an impact as you or more so I
think it's the ideas formulated wrong in
some sense I think I mean it's good to
have people that you admire let's say
who can serve as models and I'm not
claiming that I'm necessarily in that
category but it's good to have people
like that but what you want to figure
out to do to do to do is how to manifest
the ideal within the confines of your
own life right because you're a
particular sort of person and so the way
that you're going to live your life best
it's very unlikely that it would be
associated in any important way with the
way that I've chosen to live my life be
unless we have very similar temperaments
which is possible but you know
relatively unlikely because the odds
against that or it's you know
extraordinarily high the odds of any two
people having the same temperament or
very are very high so what you can do is
aim to to orient yourself towards a high
good that you can conceive of to
discipline yourself to tell the truth
and all of that and then what I would
say is that as your life unfolds you'll
have the amount of influence that you
should have whatever that happens to be
you know some people live pretty local
lives like my life for example is much
more public than my wife's life but that
doesn't mean that her contribution is
somehow lesser I mean she's being
unbelievably good with her kids my
daughter was very ill and my wife was
extraordinarily good with her and was a
great mother and it's been a tremendous
help to me as a very honest person and a
wise person and you know that all has an
impact it's just not as obvious because
well the kids really love her and now
she's got grandkids and god only knows
what the consequence of that is going to
be across successive generations and you
know she isn't interested in a public
life
journalists have asked interviewer like
quite recently about what the last
year's be like and her preference is to
not do that and and that's fine like she
has her own destiny and and her own way
of being in the world and there's
nothing to say that it's lesser in any
sense of the word at all